in dagenham the fire is out
one resident who used to call this
cul-de-sac home was escorted by the fire
service through her back garden
to see for the first time just how much
she has lost
i've lived in this house for 32 years
loads of memories
everything completely gone
a whole lot
animals missing
so i'm here today to try and find my
cats
i'm just absolutely lost for those
modest
i'm sorry
even though the worst of the heaters
passed there were more fires today this
one in upminster brought quickly under
control by exhausted firefighters many
of whom have never experienced times
like this
london fire brigade had its busiest
period yesterday since world war ii
uh it resulted in
us receiving 2 600 fight calls
and attending over 1 100 incidents
and significantly different too
moorland and grass fires are common in
the uk but seeing them go on to destroy
homes in multiple locations on the same
day is most definitely not
we associate scenes like this with
hotter drier countries than our own but
climate scientists have been warning us
for decades that as our planet warms
pushing up average temperatures the
chance of heat waves will only increase
and with them the risk of fire so while
scenes like this of wildfires destroying
people's properties are a new reality
for the uk
they should come as no surprise to us at
all
if you get hotter temperatures and lower
humidity and higher winds those are all
conditions that make fires more
prevalent if the ignition source is
there countries where fire is a real
problem like australia they know more
about how to manage urban areas and try
to minimize the amount of flammable
vegetation for example around their
homes according to the latest national
risk assessment the annual number of
wildfires in the uk has increased
significantly since 2016.
the number of days when fire risk is
high is predicted to rise even further
doubling if we warm by two degrees
celsius and quadrupling with four
degrees of warming
it's wrong to assume climate change
means we'll see wildfires every summer
weather patterns dictate when heatwaves
occur and humans influence fire risk but
our warming planet has loaded the dice
in their favor
and it's a game no one wins
tom clark sky news dagenham